pour Radio Londres j'ai kiffé parce que
je vous ai déjà dit et l'appel du 18
juin comme je suis né le 18 juin ça me
fait kiffer c'est parti
rien à dire c'est ça qui est formidable
bonsoir amiral bonsoir Monsieur Ardisson
alors quel effet ça vous fait d'être à
la télévision est-ce que vous avez le
trac quand vous venez à la télévision oh
moi j'ai pas de talent ni de goût
particulier pour la télévision
provenant de la Marine nationale nous
pratiquons la discrétion
mais mon père c'est différent il avait
appris votre perle à l'abri des
avant-guerre il avait d'abord compris
l'importance des médias il l'a appliqué
pendant la guerre
bien sûr l'appel du 18 juin pour
commencer et puis
c'est un métier qu'il a appris
finalement au fur et à mesure des années
jusqu'à le pratiquer avec une certaine
maîtrise quand il est devenu président
de la République moi je me souviens en
mai 68 quand il a fait son allocution à
la à la radio on était avec des amis
étudiants révolutionnaires dans un dans
un parc public et on l'a entendu à la à
la radio il a retourné tout le monde en
un discours on était très très fort en
radio
oui d'autant que la télévision ne
marchait pas voilà il n'avait que la
radio et la radio tu retransistes alors
pour ceux qui vous avez pas reconnu
Philippe De Gaulle vous êtes le fils de
Charles de Gaulle ancien inspecteur
général de la marine depuis 1986
sénateur
UMP de Paris alors évidemment c'est pas
facile d'être le fils du général de
Gaulle mais vous avez accepté votre
destin avec courage et modestie vous
dites j'aurais pu naître fils de pygmée
ou de Bantous le sort on a décidé
autrement on ne choisit pas sa place
pour vous votre place implique plus de
plus de devoirs que de droit d'une
certaine façon non je dirais autant de
devoir que de droit il faut pas diminuer
ce qui
c'est
tout à fait tout à fait
mais oui mais c'est ainsi il faut
assumer la place que le sort vous a
attribué
alors bien que fils du général de Gaulle
vous n'avez jamais cédé à la facilité à
20 ans vous choisissez l'armée la marine
ensuite pendant la guerre vous sillonnez
la Manche dans les vedettes
lance-torpille des Forces Françaises
Libres donc une guerre très très
courageux vous débarquez avec la
deuxième dB et vous participez à la
meurtrière campagne d'Alsace donc tout
le monde connaît l'action de votre père
pendant la guerre mais on peut dire que
vous aussi Philippe De Gaulle vu une
action très très courageuse oui je ne
pouvais pas être Autrement qu'être en
première ligne y compris dans la
deuxième division blindée alors il y a
eu 2000 livres écrits sur le général de
Gaulle votre père mais jamais le
témoignage de quelqu'un d'aussi proche
son propre fils vous êtes le dernier
témoin privilégié vivant vous dites
après moi on fera du roman vous êtes le
dernier à pouvoir certifier de ce qui
s'écrit puisque ma sœur aussi discrète
que ma mère
du silence il n'y a donc plus qu'un seul
témoin et le moment est venu pour moi de
témoigner après
on écrira ce qu'on voudra mais en moins
en râteau le plus de l'aimant
possible et en tout cas plus que ce
qu'on en a maintenant en jugé parce
qu'on écrit parfois en fait affabulation
ou de d'interprétation abusive combien
de fois ai-je entendu dire que mon père
disait l'intendance suivra oui c'est
vrai mais il n'a jamais dit ça au
contraire pour lui l'intendance
précédait toujours alors donc à 81 ans
vous parlez Philippe De Gaulle dans un
livret un livre d'entretien avec
l'écrivain journaliste Michel toriac qui
s'appelle de Gaulle mon père qui est
édité chez plomb alors le premier tome
dont nous allons parler aujourd'hui va
jusqu'en 1958 c'est à dire jusqu'au
retour du général de Gaulle au pouvoir
le deuxième tome paraîtra en février
2004 et j'espère que vous serez de
nouveau des nôtres pour pour parler du
du suivant alors ce livre évidemment
fourmi d'informations historiques et
d'éléments plus personnel a commencé par
la difficulté à s'appeler de Gaulle vous
dites finalement vous pouvez pas passer
une journée aujourd'hui sans entendre
parler du général le Gaulle c'est vrai
on a ses propres parents disparus en
soi-même on vit avec eux mais en plus je
ne peux pas passer un jour sans voir mon
nom écrit le nom de mon père pour une
question ou une autre alors en plus
comme vous lui ressemblez énormément
vous le savez vous pouvez pas aller dans
le métro vous pouvez pas aller au cinéma
c'est très difficile pour vous ça fait
partie de du statut de ce qu'on doit
assumer c'est comme ça alors quand
avez-vous pris conscience du fait que
votre père n'était pas comme les autres
qu'il était différent voir supérieur au
très tôt très tôt je dirais 4-5 ans
alors je sais que tous les petits
garçons se disent mon père est
formidable il est toujours le mieux etc
mais tout de même je me suis aperçu que
le personnage central c'était toujours
lui même quand il ne disait rien et
d'ailleurs dans le l'ouvrage que je
publie envoie une photo du
sous-lieutenant Charles de Gaulle au 33e
régiment d'infanterie qui au bout de
table des jeunes à la popote en campagne
avec les officiers de son bataillon
qui a des vieux capitaine il y a le
commandant chef de bataillon il y a
beaucoup de mais on ne voit qu'un seul
personnage c'est lui il est en bout de
table et pourtant il n'y a que lui qu'on
voit l'enfance assez difficile quand
même discipline assez ferme à la maison
est-ce que votre père vous mettez des
baffes enfin des gifles non si vous
voulez me faire dire que nous avions une
éducation prussienne certainement pas
débats on en reçoit vert quand on était
petit d'ailleurs c'est comme ça que la
lionne réagit avec le ouais ou l'ours
avec le petit il faut le ramener dans le
droit chemin et que faire avec un petit
qui met la main dans la soupe
voilà sans ça et bien c'était les
coutumes du milieu auquel j'appartenais
il fallait être dans un moule
et répondre quand vous adressez la
parole voilà à table les enfants
parlaient pas tant qu'on a pas les gens
qui pouvait parler
et il devient derrière réclamés notre
chanson là ouais si on les avait oublié
ou s'il n'avait pas de cuillère ou de
une deuxième
avait quand même la main un petit peu
plus lourde que que votre père ma mère
avait besoin de s'affirmer un peu plus
mon père avait une autorité naturelle
qui faisait qu'il avait pas besoin de
s'imposer votre mère était pas très
maternelle ma mère était une mère
parfaite c'est-à-dire que ces enfants
avaient tout ce qu'elle pouvait leur
donner mais ne les milliardisait pas
dans les caresser pour ramener sauf
quand ils étaient très petits vos
parents Philippe De Gaulle formaient un
couple indiscrétion s'imposer
c'est-à-dire que quand votre père
rentrait à la maison il embrassait votre
mère sur les joues sur le front jamais
sur la bouche devant vous ah non jamais
jamais vu non bracelait
c'était considéré comme le comportement
du couple en public alors votre père
suivait de près vos études il apprenait
des fables et des poèmes par cœur pour
vous les faire réciter tout ça insère il
la prenait lui-même ce qu'il lui lisait
trois fois le poème et puis ça voilà
et
oui en se faisant se raser pour
m'indiquer comment on devait le réciter
alors vous dites je devais être parmi
les 10 premiers de la classe il fallait
que je sois avant les autres ça c'était
obligatoire oui il disait
ça m'est égal que tu es un demi point si
les autres en zéro alors finalement vous
rentrez dans la dans la marine il s'est
jamais vraiment mêlé de votre carrière
il n'a jamais jamais beaucoup intervenu
dans votre caramélitaire finalement il a
failli vous oublier dans ses Mémoires de
guerre il a oublié finalement que vous
étiez comporté en héros pendant la
guerre et non ah bah quand même et il a
rajouté il a rajouté de sa main sur le
sur le manuscrit mon fils continue à se
battre avec la deuxième dB comment vous
expliquez ça comment vous expliquer que
finalement et vous êtes tellement mis de
côté à ce moment-là et bien parce que il
était en train d'écrire ces Mémoires de
guerre mais il ne raconte pas l'histoire
de sa propre famille à peine seulement
la discrétion et puis je lui ai dit à la
fin tout de même vous pourriez dire que
votre propre fils a fait le tout de bout
en bout et pas à l'arrière
il a dit oui c'est vrai mais je sais pas
pour raconter l'histoire de ma famille
alors il a rajouté mon fils continue à
se battre il s'agissait de la libération
de Paris point final il aurait pu
peut-être ça aurait pu arriver et écrire
mon fils a été tué il n'a pas été le
seul
vous en avez voulu de d'avoir aussi peu
de considérations finalement pour vos
pour vos faits d'armes pendant la guerre
pas du tout le savait il savait très
bien ça ne sert à rien d'être le fils du
général de Gaulle quand il faut apporter
de nuit sur un porte-avion ou quand il
faut accoster un bateau au côté il faut
être faire l'antichard avec la première
ligne d'infanterie ça sert absolument à
rien alors c'est pas la peine qu'il s'en
est là alors sur le plan historique
Philippe De Gaulle vous apportez un
éclairage évidemment sur le mois de juin
40 le refus de Paul Reynaud le président
du conseil de quitter la France il y a
sa décision à lui de partir en
Angleterre de se jeter à l'eau dit-il et
de s'en remettre à Dieu chacun un moment
et c'est un geste qui est fondateur pour
tout pour tout ce qui suit après c'est
qu'à un moment il est entré dans la
rébellion il a franchi le Rubicon il
savait pas où il allait il était tout
seul contre tous oui mais il se
considérait pas comme rebelle il était
secrétaire d'État d'un gouvernement et
il considérait que de la Troisième
République et il considérait que le
reste étant sous l'influence de l'ennemi
ne comptait pas voilà qu'il était
toujours sous les lois de la Troisième
République il n'y avait pour lui aucun
changement de régime et il se
considérait pas comme rebelle il
considérait que c'est les autres avaient
failli mais lui continuait ce qu'il
devait continuer
comme il le disait parce que c'est
l'honneur les tous nos alliés continuent
le combat aux côtés des Anglais y
compris ceux qui sont envahis comme les
Polonais les Hollandais et tout il y a
que nous qui ne continuons pas
c'est l'intérêt supérieur de la France
parce que il faut qu'elle soit
victorieuse à la fin avec tous les
autres et c'est le bon sens parce les
Allemands perdront alors souvent on se
dit dans la vie d'aujourd'hui
60 ans après on se dit qu'est-ce que
j'aurais fait moi le 18 juin 40 est-ce
que je serai parti à Londres ou est-ce
que j'aurais accepté finalement
l'occupation ou le pétainisme c'est une
question qui est centrale toujours
aujourd'hui dans la dans la vie des
Français c'est une question qu'on se
pose très souvent oui mais il y avait
beaucoup de jeunes gens à l'époque qui
n'acceptaient pas qui ne l'effondrement
de la France que pour eux ça paraissait
incroyable c'était d'ailleurs
effectivement incroyable et
aurait voulu se battre ou continuer et
non pas pu parce qu'ils se sont trouvés
très vite bloqués alors vous et votre
famille Philippe De Gaulle embarquait
donc à Brest sur un ratio pour
l'Angleterre et quand vous arrivez à
Falmouth vous savez pas vraiment où est
votre perle le général de Gaulle et
c'est là vous voyez dans le journal un
autre filet disant qu'il a lancé un
appel la veille donc on est le 19 juin
oui il a été soumis à un rythme
absolument épuisant dans les 10 derniers
jours du gouvernement français il
faisait l'aller-retour de
Grande-Bretagne France dans les 24
heures il allait à tour il revenait il
allait à Bordeaux il retournait à Brest
et par conséquent il était fréquemment
en Grande-Bretagne disons tous les 48
heures donc on savait que mon père
pouvait être en Grande-Bretagne
mais nous n'étions pas sûr de les
retrouver et nous avons traversé pour
une autre raison c'est comme j'avais une
sœur très infirme qui ne marchait pas et
qu'on ne pouvait pas déplacer en voiture
d'ailleurs en avions pas de voiture né
en pas en train pas en car alors ne pas
nous laisser dépasser par les Allemands
c'est la consigne que nous avions partir
du Bretagne Nord où nous étions en
vacances pour aller à Nantes ou à
Bordeaux avec cette fille infirme ma
mère a décidé que ça serait plus simple
de prendre un bateau pour aller en
Grande-Bretagne ce que l'avait fait en
1914 déjà une fois alors ensuite
Philippe De Gaulle vous commentez un
certain nombre d'événements historiques
de la deuxième guerre mondiale le
sabordage de la flotte à amer c'est le
Kebir la prise ratée de Dakar
l'assassinat de d'Arlan la dénonciation
de Jean Moulin et surtout l'affirmation
du général de Gaulle à l'issue de la
guerre
pour imposer la France comme un des
vainqueurs pour redonner dit-il le moral
à la nation après que le ressort ait été
cassé puisque l'effondrement politique
était devenu total
mon père a considéré qu'il n'était pas
un commandant d'art de force armées et
que il défendaient les intérêts du
peuple français il a toujours fait
valoir
autant à l'ennemi qu'à ses propres
alliés que le peuple français était
incontournable et qu'il fallait toujours
compter avec lui
c'est ainsi qu'il a commencé à apprendre
un rôle politique souvent d'ailleurs
inconfortable pour ses alliés Philippe
De Gaulle cette idée de dire aux
Français finalement la France est bien
comportée de leur faire croire un petit
peu qu'ils ont tous été résistant par la
guerre ça partait d'un bon sentiment
pour redresser le moral de la nation
mais on sait bien que historiquement
c'est faux
oh tout de même
nous nous sommes effondrés en 1940 parce
que nous avons mal organisés nous avions
des préjugés militaires périmés et nous
étions mal commandé car nous étions dans
une république qui était déjà très usée
donc les armées étaient mal commandés
mais tout de même il faut pas oublier
que en mai-juin 40 les Français ont eu
116000 tués et 600 000 blessés oui
il nous étions tout seul après après la
guerre quand votre père faisait les
comptes il voyait le nombre de gens qui
avaient été dans la résistance sur je
sais pas moi sur 40 ou 45 millions
d'habitants à l'époque ça faisait pas
beaucoup quand même il y avait 40
millions 39 39 il y avait beaucoup
d'attentistes c'est vrai mais il y avait
quand même une proportion de résistant
qui petit à petit a pu être très perporé
et monter
environ 40 000 résistants patentées
rencontrer dans des réseaux
une centaine de milliers d'autres qui
n'étaient pas dans des réseaux mais qui
les ont aidés et qui ont risqué la
capture ou même
d'être fusillés
environ de deux ou trois cent mille
autres qui les ont aidés les le peuple
français c'est quand même résiste à
résisté tout de même
il aura donné beaucoup d'importance à ce
qu'on va rester alors bien sûr pour des
raisons politiques mais aussi morales
alors vous parlez aussi donc de
l'épuration son refus de Gratier des
écrivains
collaborationnistes qui lui a été
beaucoup reproché notamment brasillac
Laval fusillés alors qu'il était dans le
coma parce qu'il avait fait une
tentative de suicide il a voulu se
suicider en absorbant un poison qui
était partiellement périmé mais il
serait mort de toute façon on aurait pu
le laisser mourir mais voilà
alors le maréchal Pétain votre père
voulait qu'il soit qu'il soit des années
évidemment sachant qu'il allait le
grassier qui le laisserait pas fusiller
mais il disait si moi j'étais tombé dans
les mains de Vichy ils auraient pas eu
autant de Clémence avec moi à un compte
stablement il aurait tout de suite été
fusil et d'ailleurs les Allemands leur
est exigés ouais ce qui fait que ils ont
fait deux processus
ils l'ont d'abord réduit au grade de
colonel et à la et à une amende et puis
sans doute les Allemands ont-ils
protesté et un mois après ils ont réuni
un conseil de guerre qui à ce moment-là
l'a condamné à mort elle a confiscation
de ses biens et elle a perte de sa
nationalité donc il l'aurait fusillé
alors que lui n'a pas fait fusiller
Pétain
souvent quand on parle en France des
Américains et de l'ancien américanisme
on se réfère au général de Gaulle et
j'ai retrouvé une phrase dans votre
livre qui finalement assez d'actualité
aujourd'hui est-ce que
c'est ne pas aimer les Américains de
considérer qu'ils n'ont pas
a décidé pour la France
non chaque pays a défendre son peuple
ses intérêts qui sont pas les mêmes il
faut rappeler ce que le papier
que les États-Unis remettaient à chaque
soldat américain qui débarquait en
France et qui était intitulé vous n'êtes
pas là pour libérer la France mais pour
combattre un ennemi des États-Unis
même si vous libérez la France c'est pas
le but de fait tous les Français même
ceux qui ont libéré les États-Unis en
autant des guerres d'Amérique sont morts
en réalité pour la France pour le roi
qui le représentait à l'époque comme les
américains les soldats américains qui
ont été tués sont morts pour les
États-Unis d'Amérique et les français
pour la France c'est tout chacun à ses
intérêts et sa personnalité propre à
défendre
aussi il faut voir que
les journalistes souvent
parce que ça faisait de la copie
exagérait les différents qui pouvaient y
avoir même s'il y avait des différences
fondamentales il y en avait c'est bien
bien sûr les États-Unis étaient à leur
place et nous à la nôtre est-ce que
l'attitude de la France face à la guerre
d'Irak vous semble dans la ligne goienne
de votre père
contre la décadence la
contre la perte de confiance en
nous-mêmes
mon père écrivait la France vient du
fond des âges elle vit les siècles la
pelle et quel que soit la situation
elle reste elle-même donc la France qui
tombe pour vous ça se corrige celles qui
se laisse aller ouais d'accord alors à
l'époque de Radioland on disait les
Français parlent aux Français
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que les Français
devraient dire aux Français il faut pas
se laisser aller au déclin toujours
garder
l'avenir n'est jamais inéluctable les
choses
les choses ne sont pas on ne peut pas
savoir trois ans quatre ans cinq ans
après ce qui va se passer les choses ne
sont pas réglées d'avance une fois pour
toute c'est à partir de l'histoire il
n'y a pas de sens de l'histoire ce n'est
pas vrai c'est une fausse théorie qui
était une doctrine mais une doctrine
très ancienne maintenant alors vous
n'êtes pas désespéré sérieusement
aujourd'hui de voir qu'en France il y a
pas d'homme politique de l'envergure de
la stature de votre père tout le monde
peut pas être le général de Gaulle c'est
ce que disait Georges Pompidou quand il
lui a succédé un jour m'invitant à dîner
la seule fois où ils mettent invité
d'ailleurs
après mon père plusieurs années il m'a
dit qu'est-ce que vous voulez je fais
comme je peux je ne suis pas le général
de Gaulle ben oui il n'est pas le
général de Gaulle
les
Chinois m'ont dit un personnage comme
votre père il y en a un tous les siècles
ou tous les deux siècles dans chaque
pays
[Musique]
alors on a beaucoup de parlé de votre
père Philippe De Gaulle j'aimerais avant
nous séparer qu'en disent un mot sur
votre fils qui s'appelle Charles de
Gaulle qui est au Front national de
Gaulle et Le Pen sur la même affiche ça
vous fait quoi
mon fils l'âge du Premier ministre son
grand-père est mort il y a 33 ans et on
l'accuse pas de autre chose d'autres
l'affaire et c'est à lui de voir c'est
son affaire
ça vous a désolé ça ne m'entraînez pas
sur ce sujet je vous répondrai pas il
est majeur et vacciné merci merci
d'avoir été avec nous
pour les plus jeunes qui nous entendent
on représente trop souvent le général de
Gaulle comme un dinosaure
hors personne ne sait plus adapté à son
temps
autant qu'il avait il a connu trois
cultures trois civilisations que le
général de Gaulle et il faut que tous
ceux qui sont ici autour se souviennent
que l'inventeur et l'incitateur
l'organisateur de la sécurité sociale ou
des ASSEDIC c'est lui votre des femmes
le vote des femmes et aussi le
régibilité de la même façon que les
hommes dit le texte et que quand il
monte dans un TGV c'est le choix du
général de Gaulle il a choisi le TGV
contre le turbo train ou le train à
coussin d'air le Concorde c'est le
général de Gaulle la Russe qui
s'appelait à erobus super Caravelle et
Caravelle générale de Gaulle le
nucléaire c'est le général de Gaulle le
périphérique autour de Paris et les
autoroutes c'est le général de Gaulle
alors voilà pour le passé en réalité le
général de Gaulle
merci beaucoup merci Philippe De Gaulle
mon père entretient avec Michel Tauriac
c'était le monsieur
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu fais non je suis juste
passé
en France
[Applaudissements]
je vais te présenter ça va qu'est-ce que
tu fais
amiral je vous présente Jamel debout
c'est une vedette alors moi je m'en vais
je connais tous vos aéroports tous les
ronds je les ai tous fait avoir un je
kiffe
voilà comme je sais que tu as beaucoup
de boulot tu travailles comme un forcené
j'ai préparé
ça doit être très intéressant mais quand
même long à lire
on prend son temps
c'est parce que j'aurais comme j'ai pas
le temps moi c'est pour ça je laisse
tiré lire il me raconte derrière
c'est ça qui est formidable
moi ce que je te je décris les questions
pour pas que tu perds ton temps tu me
fais des questions
à la con du style trompé c'est sucer
d'accord
vous restez 5 minutes avec nous ben je
vous remercie beaucoup
benjamel qu'est-ce que vous faites là
[Applaudissements]
elles sont tombées
on y va Jamel bonsoir bonsoir Thierry
alors Jamel c'est vraiment un honneur un
immense privilège d'avoir l'honneur de
vous avoir ce soir parmi nous après ces
immenses triomphes que vous avez
accumulées ces quatre dernières années
vous êtes aujourd'hui dans les acteurs
les plus doués de votre génération Jamel
si ce n'est le plus doué qu'est-ce que
ça vous fait aujourd'hui à moins de 30
ans de vous retrouver au panthéon des
acteurs français
[Applaudissements]
vous pouvez répéter la question parce
que j'ai pas
ouais le Panthéon c'est la fin non lui
il a encore 30 ans il a beaucoup de
choses à faire
alors Jamel c'est vraiment un honneur un
immense privilège d'avoir le nerf de
vous avoir ce soir parmi nous après ces
images triomphe que vous avez accumulé
ces quatre dernières années vous êtes
aujourd'hui dans les acteurs les plus
doués de votre génération si ce n'est le
plus doué qu'est-ce que ça fait
aujourd'hui de vous retrouver au
panthéon des acteurs français
je sais pas si on peut dire ça comme ça
c'est plus c'est pas moi c'est les
jeunes c'est les autres qui vont au
moins une certaine merveilleuse
extraordinaire moi je subis plus tu vois
je suis pas trop grand je fais des
choses naturellement quoi c'est le style
c'est le style c'est clair pourtant
jamais d'après le Journal de Mickey vous
êtes l'acteur préféré les enfants
[Rires]
je tiens à remercier les enfants en
particulier pour pour ça c'est vrai et
c'est jouer ça s'est joué à ça entre moi
et plutôt
et c'est vrai quand un chien débile et
un arabe qui a la classe ils ont préféré
le robot à la classe
Jamel Jamel c'est quoi vos plus grandes
qualités à part bien sûr la bogosité la
générosité lamelles unitaire
c'est très difficile de parler de soi
j'ai envie de dire la modestie
de Gaulle
alors ceux qui vend des livres c'est
incroyable ils vont 20 000 livres par
jour c'est une énorme vous allez en
vendre 500000
première
des aéroports de métro voici c'est la
nuit
qui s'appelle le Jamel Debbouze comment
je kifferais t'imagines
[Applaudissements]
t'imagines tu imagines si Philippe De
Gaulle prenait du pognon sur Charles de
Gaulle Roissy Charles de Gaulle étoile
station Charles de Gaulle et tout et fou
il pourrait s'acheter plein de cravates
de Bordeaux
alors Jamel en 2002 d'après Le Figaro
vous êtes devenu l'acteur français le
mieux payé ouais mais d'ailleurs ça va
causer pas mal de temps je dois avouer
parce que maintenant j'ai je vois venir
plein de nouveaux cousins qui sont en
galère d'oseille qui débarque comme ça
il y a encore il y a un mec qui est venu
me voir en me disant je suis le fils de
ton père
et je dis donc ça voudrait dire qu'il
serait mon frère elle m'a dit oui je
suis ton frère je t'aime mon fils voilà
effectivement mais bon je m'en sors
comme il faut et j'aimerais remercier le
Figaro pour cet article espèce de bâtard
bon Jamel alors c'est votre grand retour
sur scène en décembre vous êtes venu ici
pour en parler merci pas du tout Thierry
je suis venu en toute amitié
c'est vrai que c'est mon grand retour
sur scène en même temps faut parler un
petit peu je joue au Bataclan inch'Allah
à partir du 23 décembre jusqu'au 11
janvier c'est le Casino de Paris 23
décembre jusqu'au 11 janvier au Casino
de Paris après j'enchaîne avec le
Bataclan du 13 au 18 janvier après c'est
vrai que l'Olympia arrive le 20 janvier
jusqu'à ce que Morsang suivi
je suis pas venu pour en parler
véritablement tu me poses la question et
si vous voulez louer les places c'est à
la FNAC au verger
Jamel
[Applaudissements]
vous pouvez nous dire en deux mots de
quoi ça parle
de moi à vous c'est pour ça que ça
s'appelle Jamel 100 % debout en fait
j'aurais dit autre chose mais là
maintenant enfin voilà enfin voilà venir
voir le spectacle pour savoir de quoi ça
parle ça parle uniquement de moi ouais
ça s'appelle Lego
dans mon premier spectacle je racontais
un petit peu j'étais très surpris de
faire ce métier avec tout ce que ça
implique et maintenant hamdoulah que je
suis vraiment danse encore plus étonnant
c'est ce que je raconte ce que je vais
tâcher de raconter vous croyez que ça va
intéresser les gens
parce que tu crois que ton décor de
merde il intéresse les gens
pour faire pour venir te voir à ton
émission et tu me demandes si ça va
intéresser les gens tu crois pas
franchement ce vert il est pourri et ses
tag je sais pas qui c'est ta grand-mère
qui a fait ses tags
ils ont tortues musique qu'on fait les
tags
je vais te montrer ce que c'est que de
taguer exactement je vais faire venir
des amis à moi on va te montrer ce que
c'est que des tags quand tu veux
t'inquiète pas encore une question
monsieur Debbouze maintenant que vous
avez un succès énorme que vous croulez
sous les sollicitations vous pouvez nous
dire est-ce que sucer c'est tromper
tu vois tu peux pas t'en empêcher tu
vois je te jure profondément sadique qui
doit tu dois être ton squelette tu dois
être fait tout un sadicité c'est pas
possible tu es obligé de me poser la
question est-ce que si c'est tromper
je peux pas te répondre à cette question
je préfère le terme ma mère regarde
l'émission en plus c'est Ramadan
je reste je reste plus alors Jamel
est-ce que tant qu'il est là c'est
incroyable de l'avoir il va revenir au
mois de février Philippe De Gaulle mais
est-ce que est-ce que tu as une question
à lui poser
Monsieur
Philippe De Gaulle vous êtes donc le
fils forcément de Charles
est-ce que il aimait le rap
est-ce qu'il connaissait Tupac Shakur ou
déguisement par exemple
de son temps ça s'appelait pas comme ça
il doit arriver de danser de partir en
vrai ou pas franchement
regardez les gens dansaient mais jamais
jamais vous l'avez pris en flag dans
votre salon en train
il était très strictes
regarder ceux dont c'est le talent mais
parce que on voit les chefs d'État
de mon point de vue en tout cas je suis
pas chef d'État de mon état je me dis
que ils sont toujours obligés tout le
temps toute leur vie d'être sérieux oui
mais ça les empêche pas de s'amuser
parfois
un sourire et qu'on ne les voit pas rire
il y a des choses qui les abusent
il était il était plutôt gentil plutôt
plutôt chef d'État
mais il avait affaire à beaucoup de
difficultés forcément il n'est pas que
ça à faire en même temps on l'avait fait
venir pour ça voilà
[Musique]
merci beaucoup merci Philippe De Gaulle
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
tube abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu